we call this bit of our channel the
curriculum it's where we invite you to
come and see what the greatest minds in
the world of thought and why their ideas
matter right now it's like the ideal
university education compressed into a
range of beautiful useful little films
our curriculum is divided into eight
parts philosophy political theory
Eastern philosophy sociology
psychotherapy literature art
architecture history in each category we
look at the most important thing is the
big question we've been asking all of
them is what are the urgent things you
want to say to us today what part of
life could you help us with what's the
main advice you'd like to give the
modern world each individual film in the
curriculum is conceived as part of a
sequence which will take you around the
really vital ideas in a given field take
your time to travel around them it will
all add up to an introduction to the
most useful and interesting concepts in
the world
welcome to the curriculum at school of
life please press the subscribe button
keep up to date with the latest films in
the curriculum